rassurés et conseillers la population
fournir en matériel médical les
professionnels de santé les pharmacies
sont en première ligne dans cette crise
sanitaire ventes de gels hydro
alcooliques mais interdiction pour
l'instant de commercialiser des masques
au grand public
les dotations sont réservés aux
professionnels de santé non
comptabilisés à peu près une bonne
cinquantaine de professionnels de santé
dans un environnement géographique
proche
je vous laisse deviner la complexité de
distribuer 18 masques par personne par
semaine par professionnels de santé
sachant qu'on en reçoit à peu près 150
200 par livraison tous les quinze jours
autre activité 30 à 40 livraisons de
médicaments par jour aux personnes
seules et fragile
une solidarité interprofessionnelle
s'est mise en place avec les acteurs
médicaux du territoire on a créé un
groupe avec ses pharmaciens pour
justement attribué pour donner une
dotation minimum en masque
professionnels de santé sur que tel
médecin il raconte telle pharmacie
prendre ces dix gymnastes l infirmière
il ira dans telle pharmacie
voilà donc on a pu s'organiser de la
sorte le président de la république l'a
annoncé le port du masque pourrait se
généraliser à partir du 11 mai les
pharmacies se prépare pour répondre à ce
défi
moi je suis prête demain je peux avoir
je peux voir divine masque en tissu que
je serai prêt à vendre quasiment prix
coûtant
dans ma pharmacie pour répondre aux
besoins de la population donc j'ai
contacté alors j'ai contacté
maire-adjoint en charge de la de la
santé de montigny-le-bretonneux pour lui
dire voilà si ça va passer par vous il
n'y a pas de souci si cela passait par
mois ça peut se faire également les
pharmacies pourrait aussi s'engager dans
le dépistage de masse ici les
pharmaciens sont déjà prêts ils
attendent juste l'autorisation
administrative